our mother loved life she was very
positive
loved people so we just think it's
really important that we
we do the same exactly 30 years ago
lauren bell's
seemingly happy successful mother penny
was murdered in a particularly savage
attack
my thoughts now are that if someone can
do this
then they're gonna they will do it again
i know they will and i know what
devastation it's caused to me and my
family
as her husband and children grieved
police began their investigation
but three decades on who killed penny
and
why remains a mystery the business woman
had driven from the family home in
buckinghamshire telling builders working
on the house
she had an appointment she'd withdrawn
eight and a half thousand pounds from
her bank account
inexplicably her body was found slumped
over her car's steering wheel
found in this swimming pool car park
nine miles away in west
london she had been stabbed more than
fifty times
the money was missing penny's car was
seen driving slowly and erratically
along this road
an eyewitness said that they saw a man
in the passenger seat
and penny mouthing the words help me
through the window
it eventually pulled in here parked up
and the attack happened it was prolonged
and it was frantic in this wide open car
park
next to a children's play area with the
leisure center
just in the distance it would have been
busy and it was broad daylight the
question is
how did no one see a thing
despite countless police interviews no
one has been brought to justice
one of more than two and a half thousand
cold murder cases in england and wales
and what would your message be on the
30th anniversary i would plead with
anybody
to just help us in this situation
because
not only does it release us
from this sort of vortex of
frustration and and soul destroying sort
of
pain that we have to go through it also
takes one very bad person off our
streets
lauren hopes one day she'll have the
information to tell her own young
daughter what happened
a daughter she's called penny jonathan
samuels sky news